now after New Directions comes
disconnections disconnections is that
moment in a movie when the lovers break
up when all seems lost and for Melissa
McCarthy and spy that comes at the
moment in which it appears as though
jude law has been a double agent working
against the CIA all the time and she's
uh she's knocked out and she's tied up
and she's thrown into a dungeon along
with aldo and she says I failed it if
it's over and the disconnections is when
you're you literally have disconnected
from the people that you need to be with
and be a part of in tropic thunder Ben's
killer literally says listen you guys
can do what you want on keep I'm going
to keep on shooting the movie and he
goes back into the jungle by himself
assuming that the dead steve coogan has
cameras all over hidden cameras all over
shooting this Vietnam you're a movie and
he's going to keep on doing it so he's
literally disconnected with all the
other cast members of this movie in
Groundhog Day that's where Bill Murray
after many many tries realizes or things
he realizes he can't get Rita and so
there's no point to living and he just
gets more and more depressed ah and
that's also where it seems like Melissa
McCarthy's going to going to give up but
after the moment of this connection and
disconnection is also when the mask is
put on for a second it's the moment in
dodgeball in which Vince Vaughn who
seemed like he was becoming a nice guy
seems like he's going to be a creep sell
out his key
and take the money and just fly back to
his where you know his gym or wherever
he was from it's the moment in which
melissa mccarthy begins to doubt herself
again it's the moment in which you think
what's the point of being this nice guy
I'll just go back to being who I was so
that's for the moment the mask if you
think of a character wearing a mask
taking the mask off and there's the
Mensch there's the essence of the
character that's the moment when the
mask is put back on
you